e
uh good morning everyone um I'd like to
open uh the committee
on uh covid response and efficacy the
special committee and uh the duties of
the mission of this committee is it is a
bipartisan committee is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function in a
science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining there to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire um I would like to call on
representative leus to lead us in the
pledge
please pledge alance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all we do not have any speakers lined up
today um but I do want to let the
committee know that we will be meeting
on May 16th starting at 10:00 a.m. it
will be a full day
event um we also have um commissioner
Caswell coming in on Friday May 17th at
p.m. and I would like to uh this will be
mainly a work session uh to discuss uh
what we've learned thus far um discuss
our report and any other issues that are
open representative
beler thank you madam chair uh good
morning
everyone so I I think we've learned a
good number of things so far and one of
the things though I would like to take a
little time today to do um is to
supplement our mission statement in this
committee which identifies sort of the
what we're looking to accomplish in the
scope of what we're investigating and
looking at with a bit of a jaunt through
the New Hampshire Constitution to help
us identify our
purview our capabilities and what
actually could be done conceivably not
that we'll take every measure but could
be done um as a part of that uh
representative beler when you say
supplement our mission statement um our
mission statement is is pretty clear but
can you expand on what you mean by that
yes uh perhaps it wasn't the best choice
of words what I mean by is our mission
Sten outlines the the items to be looked
at and investigated what the the scope
of our committee is looking at um but
everything we do within that scope is
done according to the New Hampshire
Constitution so I think it would be good
idea to also look at the New Hampshire
Constitution to say okay within the
scope of our mission statement what
capacities do we have as a committee
what remedies might we offer um
ultimately uh as a part of this
committee does the committee have any
thank you madam chair so just looking to
the uh State of New Hampshire
Constitution I've got it all pulled up
here on my computer we can go through
each section that is pertinent to what
we're doing um shouldn't take too long
to do but I think it's good to look at
um let's see we have under state
constitution form of
government we have article
four the power of the general Court to
establish courts um it is within the
purview of this body this legislative
body to establish courts of record to uh
handle any issues that need to be
adjudicated in this state um and again
I'm not I'm not suggesting that we will
for the audience take every measure I'm
look we're just simply going through the
Constitution saying this is what we have
as a legislative body so we could
eventually if if we wanted to recommend
the creation of the establishment of of
a court of record to deal with any
issues relating to what we might find um
we have the power of legislation we can
uh well under house rules as they
currently exist we can't issue
legislation without a suspension of the
rules but we can certainly make
recommendations for
legislation going
forward um to be introduced at a later
time we have the we have the power of
taxation I don't think we need to look
too close to that one in this committee
right
now
[Laughter]
uh uh let's see as far as um we have the
the uh the powers and also the duty to
address
grievances um from members of the public
so as we have received or reive in the
future grievances that are related to
our mission in this committee we can
examine them and in investigate them and
make recommendations for how to how to
move forward with any appropriate
redress of
grievances um we can find that under the
Rights we can let's see
here uh I believe under under a reading
of article
83 we have the capacity to make
recommendations to the private sector as
well as
um institutions of
education and otherwise for any needs
that we may come across for instance if
we were to find that there's a glaring
scientific need for Research into a
particular item we can make
recommendations to to the institutions
and public sector to to pursue those
um so something to the effect of uh
recommending uh specific guidelines for
air filters to help mitigate viruses
would that be one of those items that we
could recommend or I'm just trying to
understand when you say I believe
strictly speaking something like that
would be addressed through legislation I
this I think is more in terms of if we
discovered for instance that there
was
um some problem that came up as a part
of the vaccine roll outs or something to
that effect that that that
rendered um that rendered us with a with
a problem within the broad body politic
we could instead of instead of dealing
with directly legislation we could say
okay we have a bunch of universities in
this state they do a lot of research we
can appeal to them it's not a mandate we
can't make them necessarily do this
stuff but we can appeal to them to
consider investing some funding and time
into investigating this particular
matter to look for Solutions because
that's just part of their charge under
their what they do so similar to people
that um switched over to make hand
sanitizers um during the pandemic period
sure yeah and and there was there was uh
I believe executive orders that provided
some relief from regulation that allowed
them to pursue uh switch overs like that
um and that's something that we could I
mean there's nothing stopping us as well
from from uh making recommendations to
the executive branch for um executive
orders or ex as well as exercising our
oversight of what has occurred um making
recommendations for future if there is
another emerging event or pandemic that
comes up um as well as exercising
judicial oversight um and also
exercising oversight over our state
federal relation
what kind of funds were received what
kind of mandates or you might say
strings came with any of those funds and
whether there is anything in the future
that needs to be done differently um
those can be all within our purview I
believe comfortably within our
constitutional mandate as a
committee does anyone have any other
comments uh relating to what uh
represent Bela was just discussing
represent
vus I think it's great spelling out our
powers more specifically according to
the Constitution thank you
welcome is there anything else uh that
anyone would like to
discuss um regarding our duties or how
we're functioning things that we're
doing right um
anything further that we need to discuss
representative
HOV just a s that uh I I had as I was
listening uh we mentioned the power of
taxation and it's definitely that people
are already taxed enough but also um
like my thought was uh that one of the
problem that we had here and otherwise
is that uh people who are injured for
example by
vaccines are having
trouble receiving proper compensation
even though uh government established uh
St federal government established a
special fund for those purposes so I
just wonder if if the fund is not enough
and that's why people are being uh to
around or other other reasons why it's
that process is so honorous on on
victims uh just a sort so
probably because it's
already inside the government uh so
probably it's not a case of additional
taxation that is needed but uh something
to think
about uh represent
beler thank you madam chair and I I
would just add to that uh speaking
directly to the audience the general
public that what we're doing as a
committee obviously we establish this
committee we asked to establish this
committee we want to move forward with
these
investigations but we're doing this
primarily based on based on the public
based on uh grievances based on
petitions um because we've heard we've
heard from you and we would like to
continue to hear from you um about any
items related to our purview within our
broad uh investigation of the co
efficacy and our state response to covid
so for those listening um if you have
items that you think were done well or
items that you think were not done well
items that you think may have been in
violation of your rights or anything of
that matter we do receive grievances if
you have petitions for us or anything of
that nature we are happy to accept those
and look at them and to see if they fall
within our perview for our uh duties
you represent
leus can you go over what specific
things we'll be covering that we have
scheduled already and um if there are
any days that we have scheduled for the
public to be able to come in and and
answer Mike's questions so
representative bel's questions thank you
for that question first off I'd like to
let everyone know that if anyone wanted
to email the this committee we
are a standing committee under the New
Hampshire house and they can go on there
and click there and uh send an email to
um
anybody in here um in in this um it it
has all our contact information so they
can send an email to the special
committee
specifically um May 16th we will be
having a full day um and I don't think
there'll be any time for
um the topic will be dealing with
Federal U
mandates and also the vaccine roll out I
believe I I am we have a speaker coming
in um who is well vered in a lot of what
our mission
is
um so I think um they will be present
have a PowerPoint
presentation uh on the 17th um
commissioner CLE will be coming in at 2:
p.m as I mentioned
earlier
um and he will be
discussing uh the federal funds or the
funds that were dispersed through
gopher
um and I am sure he will be able to
speak also to that guidance um of how it
was uh rolled out um and if there are
any questions from this committee if we
could get those uh specific questions
together for him I know representative
eel's already uh has some questions that
she would like to uh
see a you know answered if anyone else
here I can send those out to him to give
him a heads up um but he was
instrumental in
issuing the funds uh through the
state uh so that everyone knows um
earlier in that day if we decide to meet
earlier that day um uh that there'll be
room for the
public um and right now those are the
only two dates currently
scheduled um I'm possibly looking to
schedule a
Tuesday at some point um not sure which
Tuesday would work for everybody if
Tuesday would work for anybody here um
because once we get past this uh through
the 16th I believe all house deadlines
have had to be met um with regards to
bills and then I believe it would just
be special hearings um we are still
trying to get director buckton to commit
to a date that's why I'm thinking of a
Tuesday um and if we can get a specific
Tuesday I'm sure that he won't be here a
full day and we can have the public come
in at that time um but if there is
anybody that would like to come in and
speak
um and if they could just reach out and
then we could schedule meetings uh just
uh to hear from them if we have uh one
one person we can put them in with
somebody else if we have several people
we could do a a day just for the public
uh to come and discuss uh what's going
on I think um having uh the mom here the
last time time we met um was really eye
openening as I had said it was um was
heartbreaking but it was also
um
insightful into um the response and how
it affected children how it affected
Families how it affected uh personal
relationships Etc and to touch on
know with respect to getting
reimbursed uh through the government
funded
site
um because of the time
frame they were not able to do so I
believe is what she had mentioned I
would have to double check her
testimony but
[Music]
um uh represent
of just follow up on on that so that
it's probably not an issue of uh
taxation that there's not enough
taxation because some other funds were
over how to say over permissive and
issuing funds we know that many small
businesses were receiving compensation
for being closed and there was a lot of
fraud when some non-existent businesses
uh some fous business names were used to
receive those funds and the fraud was
so so huge that government doesn't have
resources to go after every every case
of of that so we see that in some cases
uh like some compensations and other uh
Co response related funds were
distributed too freely but in some cases
I feel like like uh there was too much
tension represent
leus is one of the speakers who's coming
on in the 16th or 17th able to answer
how those decisions were made so that we
make sure if this ever happens again we
don't we have a process that doesn't
allow for that fraud I I think that um
that would be more of a question for
commissioner Caswell on the
17th and or director buckon who is also
uh with Homeland Security in New
Hampshire who handled the federal
funds
um there was a lot of money flowing
through um the state and from the
federal government
um so I know that um and there were many
many people trying to um get their hands
on money even if they weren't entitled
um it's
unfortunate uh but that is was the way
it was and that's just Society I think
and we'll always see uh fraud no matter
what's going on um there are people that
they try really hard at it um as you
have we hear about that all the time um
and I don't think that would be the
purview of this committee um to look
into to that um that would just be too
owner that would have to be another
committee um to look into things like
that um because our Focus really needs
to be
on the administration of the federal
Guidance the acceptance of the federal
funds the implementation of the
emergency use authorization vacc
um and um how that affected different
areas as we know it affected
education it did affect the private and
the public sector it affected everybody
technically but I think uh for us to
really look
at
um the abuses in the federal
funds we just wouldn't be able to do I
think what is really the focus of this
committee
um so I mean I think um you know we've
learned a lot uh so far even though
we've only had a few meetings uh we had
the industrial hygienist in here uh
Steve Petty um and I learned more about
masks than I ever thought that I would
know I learned about microns and
droplets um and I didn't know that the
reason doctors or surgeons wear masks is
because of droplets and that's why
they've always worn them um I didn't
know that on an n95 mass that you had to
be professionally fitted for that and I
thought think that is a really piece of
important information and I think that
the information that we learned about
mask uh should be um one of the things
topics in our
report because what we did learn is that
the covid virus was I forget what the
number of the Micron was but no no ma a
mass that we had readily available to us
could actually prevent
that uh stop that mic that virus from
being expelled from us or even with the
mask on getting into us and I think
that's really important to understand
and I think in the future or when we're
we're going to implement policies we
need to look at that and say gee is this
a virus and if this is
microns you know what is the effect uh
of that I think that's important uh for
the public to understand and so that we
don't have a false sense of security in
my opinion um because of that
representative
Bel thank you madam chair and just to um
follow follow on with what you were just
saying I think I think there is a um a
trend or a
um something that's been ongoing in the
Judiciary at the at the federal level
recently which parallels what you were
just sort of talking about which is if
you'll give me a second to explain the
idea of an intermediate versus a strict
scrutiny which is used in adjudicating
um cases often times uh in the Judiciary
with and forgive me these paraphrasing
these definitions but the idea being
that where constitutional rights are
implicated under a uh strict skirtin
Paradigm um there is an extraordinarily
high level of burden of proof placed on
the government that it is wholly
necessary to do this whatever this is um
to override that um that individual
right versus a more intermediate level
of scrutiny which merely suggests that
the government only have to prove that
it might be useful to do so basically
not perfect definitions I don't have
them up in front of me but the idea
being that perhaps and this is something
we'll discuss I'm sure when it comes to
issuing a report but perhaps um there
needs to be some sort of a
recommendation going forward that
anytime individual constitutional rights
are implicated we need to be operating
more along the lines of a strict
scrutiny than an intermediate scrutiny
where we really have to have a burden of
evidence that is significant on the part
of the government um before we can
simply tell people you have to do this
this thank you for for that um that's
very helpful in um explaining to
myself um I'm sure as to others on how
things are guided I also think on that
lines is what we did learn regarding
mask is that the medical profession
isn't the one that understands
masking they understand
medicine um and they're a
specialist
uh and that understand how masks work
and I think um one of the
things that and I'm not sure and we'll
get I'm sure we'll find out as we have
people in from the state on how they
received the federal guidance and did
they do their own investigation and did
they bring in their own specialist in
those areas or did they just take the
word uh and said that this is the way it
is um because again what we heard from
the gentleman that was here was that
when all of this was happening he went
into a
school uh that was uh a special needs
school where the masking issue was going
to create a serious problem and they
instituted
protocols um where they didn't mask at
all and they had zero cases of covid um
I
think I didn't even know that there was
a whole industry out there that
specialized in mask understood the
different properties a mask or anything
like that and so for me that was
extremely enlightening um and I'm sure
for most people they would think that
you know your medical profession would
would be the ones that would understand
that but they receive guidance from
these specialist um so I think one of
the things that
we need to look at and we need to ask
going
forward is are we bringing in the proper
specialist to give us
guidance representative Belcher thank
you again Madam chair and again I'll
follow up a little bit on what we're
talking about here because I think
there's two completely unrelated very
important points to pull out of what you
were just saying which is um we looked
from what we've gathered so far are very
myopically a very narrow focus on one
set of ideas about how to contain the
outbreak of covid we we settled on um
primarily masking whereas what we've
heard is very few places took a more
sensible approach um of environmental
controls where an item that would have
had minimal impact on anybody's um
individual rights or their ability to
choose whether or not to wear a mask um
was overlooked in so many cases and
probably would have resulted in a less
expensive and higher efficacy weight
path forward um so that's something
we'll definitely want to take a closer
look at and the other item was oh yes uh
this is important as well one of the
things I'd like to get more information
on regarding a lot of these mandates
that came up for various places I I
wonder to what degree litigiousness
played into various decisions um because
we do have somewhat of a you know
litigious Society at at at the moment
perhaps not as much as back in the 90s
but was there a fear of of
lawsuits that drove some of this um what
you might call
safetyism that drove certain
requirements on people to do various
things and because this brings up a very
important point about what we just went
through as far as our constitutional
abilities uh again inside article 83 we
have the the ability and the duty to
offer
immunities where necessary to protect
people's rights so what that might mean
is something we could consider
recommending if we discover that there
was any degree of litigiousness or fear
of Suits behind any of these mandates
we could consider legislation or
something of that effect in the future
offering immunity from civil
suit um in situations where individual
rights would otherwise be
overridden with
mandates for instance you know hospitals
they they wouldn't have to worry about
being sued if they don't force people to
wear a mask or or be vaccinated for
covid or whatever it may be we have the
ability to offer these civil immunities
that might be able to protect individual
rights
better represent beler just a question
um regarding that um the
hospitals instituted a strict uh
protocol where no
visitations to anybody in a in the
hospital
um would that be something that you're
speaking
to that would be at least adjacent to
something that I'm speaking to the idea
I I'd have to work it out exactly how
that issue might work in this regard but
for instance if you were saying a
hospital is now being told by some
higher entity that they
should block people from being able to
access patients in the hospital in order
to do infection control well now you've
got a a should it's not quite a mandate
but it's a recommendation coming down
from perhaps a federal level or some
other organization
well in theory if they don't do that and
now you have a problem where there's an
outbreak or whatever in theory you could
have a lawsuit on those grounds saying
you failed to follow this guidance so
did litigiousness in that kind of an
instance Drive these policies they may
have I'd like to know more about that
but one thing we could do is write
legislation that says people have these
rights to be able to do these certain
things perhaps we could say that we
believe people have a right to visit
their loved ones especially when they're
ill they're dying whatever ever and you
will be immune from civil suit if you
allow this to
happen uh not to be um
adversarial however uh do you believe uh
that there are cases uh of infect highly
contagious diseases where people should
not be able to go into that section um
just thank you and that that is that is
a bit of a complicated question because
you have you know differentiation
between something like covid blue versus
Ebola so those are those are very very
difficult questions to answer but I
would always eror on the side of
individual freedom and say if somebody
has somebody who's sick and dying of a
of a very contagious nasty
disease if there is any ability
whatsoever to fit that person with
adequate uh protective controls to
prevent the spread of infection then I
think they probably ought to be allowed
to do so um waving any right to uh a
civil suit if they're uh if they were to
contract something in order to be there
to hold the hand of of a Dying loved one
I think even with some of the more
severe diseases they think that could be
appropriate again if they can be
outfitted with the proper protective
equipment okay okay so as long as they
operator can be with uh
PPE
um then you're saying it's okay because
my concern would be that um in the case
of Ebola or something that
um there was something and they went out
and they spread that into the public so
I I think um we have to be cautious I
understand Co is different than baa um
and and I think that's something that we
need to look at right I mean we need to
look at
um Co is a virus um it's I personally
call it the flu on steroids
um
um deadly for some people as is the flu
as is monia I mean we have all kinds
of uh viral and bacterial uh infections
that are deadly to certain parts of the
population depending on age depending on
um you know complications and different
health issues um and the other thing
that I think we learned is that from Co
from um I believe it was Dr kof that t
talk to us
is
that based on what we know we know the
population that was most
affected and we know the
population and I'm not sure how quickly
we learned that but I think we learned
pretty quickly who wasn't getting covid
and who was um and I think that's
something that we really need to in the
future
uh really maximize on
um because yes we needed to protect our
El elderly uh and I think New Hampshire
did that pretty well I mean we that was
our first population that we we looked
at and I think that was a really really
um but we also know that um the younger
people aren't as affected uh by this and
really weren't catching it or even
transmitting it is my understanding
so and we know that the next one coming
down the pike could affect a different
population we don't know what population
it will affect but I think in in when we
give out our guidance we need to be
looking at it's not necessarily the
entire population that's going to be
affected by something it's usually
targets certain sectors of the
population and I think that's something
important to
note representative Le yeah I just want
to pick up comments on each of the last
few yeah things
um one regarding Hospital visitation I
would think that whatever the hospital
was using to attend to that
patient their family should be able to
use and in sometimes that might just be
looking through a window but sometimes
that might be a full get up or or
whatever um
so I think that would we wouldn't have
to know the specifics for that we would
just be able to recommend that whatever
the H whatever safety precautions the
hospital Personnel are using that would
be appropriate for the family to allow
them in um as far as things we
learned when we were talking about Mass
we were talking about other things and
to me what struck me was if you have a
full
system like newer buildings do as HVAC
system um you can put
one one item in there and it would
kill what a 99 point something percent
of the virus that's in an Airborne virus
I mean we're talking about different
things but in an Airborne virus and for
schools that don't they could put
individual things but in the meantime
they could open their windows and I
don't think we did enough of that and to
me that was striking is how much just
how much effect just fresh air had and
just opening the windows in our
houses as far as inside and being
outside as much as possible what a an
improvement that would have made and
that was one of the things that really
struck
me what was the last thing you were
I had a list I should have written them
on I don't remember well if it comes to
one of us I did have a comment to make
on
that um the other thing just expounding
on what you just said is you know we
closed down the
beaches and what in discussion is Sal
air actually
helps get rid of viruses along with the
sunshine and everything else which also
produces vitamin D and everything else
uh to help people represent leus well
along those lines um one of the things I
think our state did very well was
encouraging people to get outside was
having the state parks open was
encouraging people to go visit them I
think that was excellent given that
there were other states who were
arresting people people for mowing their
lawn you know so that's that's something
that I think we did very well represent
beler thank you madam chair and I would
I would tend to agree with that um at
the state
level I think there were some some
positive decisions made as far as
keeping outdoor areas open accessible
and whatnot however there were some
exceptions to that that we're not
strictly at the state level that we
things we could look at for instance we
mentioned closing the beaches that was a
decision made at the local level but we
are a Dylan's rule state and Dylan's
rule means that individual localities
can only do what they are allowed to do
as has been delegated by this body uh
and the one on the other side of the
wall concurrently to them to be allowed
to do so if if we didn't want them to
have the ability to shut down the
beach we could make modifications to
that uh in law
uh and also at the federal level I I
know this because I live a bit further
north and I know that the federal
government shut down the White Mountain
National
Forest all the hiking trails all the
nature the campgrounds they were
shut and while again at the state level
we made some relatively smart decisions
to keep things open as we could as far
as outdoor things
go um I think we really need to look at
at um again the the local decisions that
were made and whether they ought to have
the ability to make those decisions
under such a case
and the the federal matter of shutting
down one of our greatest natural
resource sources in the state the the
White Mountain National Forest as well
as the other Federal um parks and lands
in this state I think that that ought to
be uh looked at pretty hard thank
you uh and just touching on uh both of
what you're all talking about about
being
outside and bringing back in um both our
speakers uh from a few weeks
ago the social distancing
number because we're still asking people
and I think one of the reasons the
beaches were shut down is because of
social distancing not necessarily
because because of the
crowds and what we
discussed was there was no scientific
base is for 6 foot social
distancing now I don't know about
everybody else but I just
assumed and shame on me that that was
done
scientifically and it
wasn't there was no scientific data it
was a random number that the federal
government came up with and everyone ran
and representative beler thank you madam
chair I would just add to that that we
received testimony in this committee
that the state of New Hampshire actually
used I believe it was a three-foot rule
uh recommendation when it came to
schools because it was Impractical to
conform with the six-foot rule of the
federal government given our school
situation so we went with ref feat and
apparently some people thought that was
good enough even though the federal
government was say saying 6 feet and it
doesn't seem like either of those had
any basis in evidence-based science it
it was simply a matter of
guesswork uh somewhat in the same manner
of although perhaps a little more
understandable this idea of the Swiss
cheese approach that they took to
mitigation where they decided to throw
everything at it to see basically see
what's stuck um unfortunately what that
meant is uh you there was so many
confounding variables that you couldn't
tell if anything worked at all or if
anything had a negative effect
individually you could tell the the full
series of precautions together you could
say well this may have done that but
each individual item within there there
was really no way to control for all the
other variables to see what if anything
worked and I I think we can say
generally the cumulative effect of that
I can't say a number as terms of
efficacy but I can say that
overall was not efficacious because it
seems like just about everyone in this
state got covid regardless of what
took I agree with you 100% on that um
and what I am seeing is
that a people that weren't vaccinated
getting covid people that had one
vaccination getting covid people that
have been double vaccinated getting Co
and people that have had every
vaccination getting covid
um
so I don't
think I understand that they were
concerned about overloading the uh
hospitals um obviously that's what we
were all told that the reason we were
doing everything is because they didn't
so I kind of
understand maybe a little but I really
don't once they found out that we the
hospital stays the hospitals weren't
being
overwhelmed when you know why not why
not stop or why not pull back on
something representative
leus yeah I was thinking about the
effect of people who could not get in to
see doctors and who had appointments
cancelled Etc because they were trying
to make sure and leave that open but um
one of the things we haven't looked at
yet is the harms that were done to the
people because they couldn't get
the um appointments Etc that they needed
manner represent Belcher thank you madam
chair and again to follow up on that
same line of thinking and I would love
and I very much hope if we get some some
real experts and people in here from
from hospital associations from uh
Hospital owners from hospital
administrators to give us some good hard
data on this because it is my
understanding that
because there were a combination of
mandates and
recommendations that caused people to
not be able to pursue normal Health Care
there were people just they just shut
everything kind of down they didn't they
weren't taking normal patients for
everyday kind of things it's my
understanding that hospital capacity was
reduced because the lot the lack of
income to
hospitals um actually CA and and the the
the emptiness
actually caused people to shut down to
to cut cut back on total scale so I
would love to get some statistics such
as we hear about the possibility of
hospitals being overwhelmed well how
many beds were available in each
Hospital in this state one year prior to
covid the day that covid or you know
maybe January of
21 and then January of 22 what were the
total availability of beds not not
availability but the total number of
beds in each Hospital in each
ICU and I want to know if there was a
loss of capacity that happened as a
result of uh this this whole
circumstance so represent of belg would
you say that you would want to know uh
based on your questioning how many beds
were empty how many beds were occupied
in each of those years thank you I I
would love to know how many were
occupied and how many were empty but
overall I want to know just how many
there were altogether cuz I want to know
if there was a financial impact to
hospitals because of decisions that were
made that actually resulted in a loss of
capacity within the hospital system
generally and I think that brings us
through to today which I think uh this
effect is still happening today I
believe I saw on the news last night and
I could be mistaken uh that over in Keen
they're shutting down the ICU
unit
um but I would have to double check um
it was I was sitting somewhere and I
just saw something flash up quickly
but representative belch thank you uh
and and yes to and to that point I would
I would add not just do I want to know
beds but I also want to know Staffing as
far as um adequate Physicians adequate
nursing Personnel um and any others who
are required to keep hospitals
functioning because I guess at the end
of the day if you've got 200 beds but
only enough staff to cover 150 of them
that's an important thing to know too so
I'd like to get this these numbers over
time starting before Co during Co and
and now to see what the impact has been
uh to our system in
general represent blus to that effect um
how much did the vaccine mandates affect
the Staffing because I know here the
conquered hospital I did talk to a
number of those um professionals and
they were talking how many of them had
left um because they
were from what they saw they did not
want to get the
vaccines and had already gone and gotten
other jobs and they were talking about
how
they were almost on emergency Staffing
at that point so and they didn't know
what would happen once the deadline
passed and people were forced to leave
um they weren't sure that they could you
know they were they were predicting that
people would would start to die from
lack of Health
Care I can tell you that at the county
level and I'm sure that each of you have
experien this with your own County
nursing homes
um that the mandates truly did affect
the
Personnel um but it was more than that
because of federal guidance that came
down the contractors or subcontractors
going to the nursing home had to comply
with the vaccines and so therefore they
were having trouble getting work done
um
because they had to be documented and
show um that they were complying with
all the mandates uh coming down from the
federal government um and not the state
government but the federal government
um
so I think also there might have been
some disconnect into what the state was
saying and then what the Fed ederal
government was telling the state and I
think that's something that we really
need to delve into too is to look at
what federal mandates what did the state
want to do what did we have to do
because of the the federal mandates um
and how did it affect our care I know
that you know our nursing home our
County Nursing Home level dropped in the
number of patients they could have um
and
because they deal with Medicaid and
Medicare dollars um they have to be very
cautious because those monies will be
withheld um for re from reimbursement if
they don't comply with the federal
guidance over the state guidance um and
I know in our area it had a drastic
effect um on services at the county
level represented beler thank you madam
chair and and to follow again and kind
of the same idea I'd like to get
information from I I suppose it would
probably be
DHHS regarding and I think we may have
actually posed this question but I'll
say it here anyway um what was known
over time about the efficacy of the
various uh vaccines and mRNA injections
for covid um it's going to play into
this idea about about mandates uh for
healthc Care Professionals
because right now the argument that I
hear made most often for vaccination is
that it reduces mortality and that's
primarily amongst the elderly and there
may actually be a net benefit to some of
the people in a certain age group from
the vaccine for reducing mortality
that's entirely
plausible but the only the only
reasonable argument for making a
requirement of the vaccine among among
Healthcare
professionals would be if it actually
prevents you from
spreading the virus to your patient
population that's the only reasonable
argument we made for it and it seems to
me that by the time we had one or two um
boosters rolled out it was it was
evident that the ability of this of
these vaccines to prevent the spread of
the virus was at at best
minimal um again there may be a benefit
to mortality especially in a certain age
group but what was originally said the
idea that if and I this came from
federal officials said if you get the
vaccine you will not get the virus well
it it didn't take long for that to be
demonstrated to be inaccurate um and as
I said basically almost everyone seems
to have gotten it eventually despite the
presence of vaccines so I'd like to know
know when we understood at a
professional level that the vaccines did
not have a substantial effect on the
transmissibility of the virus and how
that overlaid with various mandates
Professionals that is an interesting
uh question and very thoughtful I didn't
actually think of it that way and I
appreciate you're bringing that up
representative beler representative
le as I recall and it would be nice to
get verification on this but um before
and at the beginning of the vaccine roll
out the federal government was saying
that it would not was known that it
would not stop the spread therefore
masks and if that was known why were we
mandating well the other question is is
as we learned about mask why did they
say that we had to wear a mask and who
was driving that bus and did they have
specialist uh looking into the Micron of
the virus versus the microns that the
mask actually
stopped represent
black the other thing um based on
testimony that we heard is that we've
had
no um deaths of was it children under
five children under 12 I don't remember
what the number was due to the vaccine
but we've had a number I mean due to the
due to covid but we have had a number
due to the vaccine and yet we are still
pushing vaccinations for young people
and I would love love to know why we're
still doing
that I I think the bigger question is is
were those dollars coming from for the
advertisement of it um is it from the
state is it from ARA funds or is it from
federal funds I mean I understand arar
federal funds but is there still money
coming down for that I guess is is the
question represent Bel thank you madam
chair and my prior question that I posed
appli to that situation in exactly the
same manner which is it it didn't take
long for us to understand as a society
that this was not a virus that had at
least
acute nasty effects for children the
long-term effects it's a little harder
to know but the the acute phase this was
not tending to kill
children so the same argument applies
and we heard this over and over again
that effectively we need to vaccinate
children so they don't kill grandma
but that argument relies on the idea
that the vaccine stops the transmission
of the virus so at what point did we
know that the vaccine did not actually
stop the transmission of the virus
despite possibly having a mortality
benefit or populations elsewhere we knew
that it didn't stop the transmission of
the virus and did we then stop
I'd like to switch topics a little bit
um we heard from the commissioner of um
education commissioner edel
blo um who testified here that he tried
to give a uh positive
message uh out to people
but then we also have heard from the
public that fear was instilled with in
them basically uh every
day
um I know I can
testify to this
committee that I was on a phone call um
they have White House intergovernmental
phone
calls uh and they were having one um I
believe was in April of May uh right
after the
shutdowns and the call was about mental
health of the shutdown it was
about the rise in
alcoholism it was about the rise and
[Music]
addiction so early
on being on that call with people at the
federal
level they knew
[Music]
knew and I shouldn't say they knew but
based on the phone call there was a
great understanding that this shutdown
would increase mental health issues
would increase addiction would increase
alcoholism
call and as I was listening and then saw
what we were doing not only as a state
but as a
country knowing that the long-term
effects of this were going to be Untold
and we didn't know how many years out we
were going to continue to see the
effects of this why it took so
long to get the information out and
why
wasn't helping people and putting things
in a positive light instead of scaring
everybody and putting fear into them and
affecting their mental health and
increasing addiction and alcoholism and
education why did we let the artive go
on I understand that we need to be
concerned about public health and public
policy is
important but I think sitting here in
this committee listening to some of
these Specialists I don't think the
Specialists were contacted I
think that there was a
narrative and I am truly truly
concerned that the truth was kept from
us
not totally and I don't want to say that
because I think at the beginning nobody
knew I really do believe we were all
guessing but when I'm telling you that
it was in April or May of that year
after the shutdowns in March they were
already talking about these
issues that's that's a problem and it's
something that while we're talking about
the shutdowns and telling people to do
this and issuing these mandates we
needed to be talking about these other
issues um and the effects that it could
have on people the delay in the
education of their children the delay by
wearing a mask how you're hindering a
child's communication
skills um and the way they communicate
in the way they
understand that creates long-term
issues I knew a school
teacher who had a student come back to
school and was so
uncomfortable removing his mask because
he didn't know how to be without it
anymore he was
afraid I think that in our report
although we're looking at the federal
mandates but the emergency use and the
guidance we need to be looking at the
true effects and the mental health
issues and what we what has how it has
affected Society in general I think
I understand that's very broad but I
think it's extremely
important representative
to uh sort of follow up on on the
concept um of Public Health and I I want
to officially go on the record and and
offer this argument for the committee's
consideration and others as to what I
see is as a fundamental problem that
might be something we either this
committee or us as legislators can
eventually look to address
so public health is a little bit of a
misnomer okay so the public doesn't have
health people have health I have health
you have health I have health problems
the public has
statistics regarding health so when you
when you take the concept of Health away
from the individual and you put it on
the public you're dealing with
Statistics and immediately right off the
bat you're collectivizing you're taking
it away from the individual and toward a
collective and that lens when you begin
to look at things through a public
health lens you cannot help but begin to
view people by populations by
demographics instead of as individuals
with individual rights and individual
agency to make their own
decisions um and that brings us into
some very very dangerous territory where
through the lens of Public Health nearly
anything can be
justified if it is of net
benefit in theory to the
public and it's my personal belief may
not be shared by other groups but it is
my personal belief that the legitimate
functions of Public Health should
probably be seen as defense
functions and the idea of Public Health
generally should go away in favor of
individual health individual agency and
making
represent uh thank you
so to follow up on previous uh could you
give
some concrete example as it
uh um relate to co
response how it would be different if we
would be uh focused on individual health
instead of Public Health
because
um I don't know if I fully understood
your
concept sure and I I hate to get too
detailed because this is more of a
general concept but I can give you I can
give you one example that seems in my
mind to make sense so let's take the
concept of of masking to begin with now
this was as we heard part of what was
called a Swiss cheese approach where we
effectively just threw everything at the
wall to see what's what would stick
right and from the public health lens
this was seen as a collective item to
get everybody to do this thing in the
hopes that if everybody did this it
would lower the total um what you would
call AR not or rate of spread of the
disease low enough to not overwhelm
hospitals or cause significant
individual harms to people people when
if we were to look at this more through
an individualist lens we would actually
see that well first of all people have
agency and they people are not fully
rational by any means but they do tend
to make decisions in their own benefit
all right if you didn't do that every
single day you wouldn't live very long
so people have the ability to make
decisions for thems and if you were
looking at the circumstances as they
rolled out you might have thought to
yourself well
why would I ask all of these other
people to wear a cloth mask that
definitely doesn't offer any protection
if I were to wear a cloth mask that's
not going to prevent me from getting
sick I might instead choose to wear an
n95 or n100 mask that although we've
heard at this point that that probably
wouldn't have worked either because of
the various issues that go on with it at
least an individual might have thought
themselves well if I wear an n95 or n100
I can prevent myself from getting sick
and if I'm relying on myself and my own
agency and my own actions to prevent
myself from getting sick and staying
safe I don't have to worry about what
these other hundred people around me are
doing because I'm protecting myself I'm
taking rational actions to protect
myself and when you think along those
lines it provides a lot less um impetus
to universally regulate everything
require everybody to do the same thing
and to demonize people who won't go
along with the program because they
might have a different thought about
things so let me just understand
representative Belcher um based on
represen PO off's question um I had
constituents
um that are highly H
claustrophobic and so wearing a mask
mask was an
extremely uh emotional and very
difficult thing for them to do just even
to go into a doctor's office um there
were also other people
um that have had other traumatic things
happened to them and a mask reminded and
brought up those uh
images um and they had to relive
something over again again a mental
health issue so basically if they felt
that it was better for them or healthier
for them
[Music]
um not to wear one based on what you're
saying as an individual versus a public
acceptable yes I I think again when you
when you look at things through an
individual lens where we all have agency
and we make somewhat rational
decisions you can say okay
well maybe the mask is going to help me
a little bit but my claustrophobia
regarding this is going to my
life my livelihood and you might decide
as an individual that the risk or
downside of that outweighs the the
positive side of that and perhaps some
people think well that's a crazy thought
but is it actually a crazy thought when
that person actually almost certainly
sit statistically caught Co anyway even
mask yeah but we didn't know that people
were going to everybody uh was going to
Catch Co at the time I'm just go playing
going along here um we know that most
people or I know
that basically not everyone that has
been vaccinated but most people that I
know that have been vaccinated have had
covid at one point or another um
um but I think that also took some time
um but what I did know do know from
listening is with the microns which to
me was even more important but I
understand what you're saying about the
individual um I think one of the things
that people weren't taking into
consideration is the how things are
going to affect people's mental health
and I think that when we look at any
pandemic or anything in the future we
need to look at the mental health of of
people individuals
um you know is it going to increase
alcoholism is it going to increase drug
addiction you know I mean these are side
effects that we don't we're not
discussing is this going to increase
delayed learning is you
know all these issues
I think when we're looking at these
level I don't know if they've were
looked at ahead of time and I guess I
would ask the question were they looked
at ahead of time representative Bela
than representative thank you madam
chair and just to just to help flush out
what I was suggesting about the public
health lens what you were just
suggesting I think is generally accurate
because we we need to take in the
totality of things when we're making
decisions like this um we we've we know
we've seen an increase in what we call
deaths of Despair related to mental
health issues related to drug and
alcohol abuse and whatnot but the
difference between an individualist lens
versus a public health lens let's take
alcohol for instance well if we looked
at this through the public health lens
and said well if we make this decision
regarding these shutdowns and these mass
and everything else we're going to we're
going to drive an increase in alcoholism
and and all the problems that come along
with that well the public health
solution to that very well might be
let's enact prohibition let's ban
alcohol But the individualist lens to
that might look at that same situation
and say well maybe we should actually
let people do what they think is best
from the word go so we don't have these
side effects like increased alcoholism
and we let people go on about their
lives make their own decisions and their
own
interests represent
leus following Along on these just from
a personal point of
view with my asthma which was very
kicked up for the first while of that
anytime I put on a mask my O2 would
drop and so basically I didn't go
anywhere because I couldn't I would have
to wear a mask but if I wear a mask then
and I couldn't
breathe and um I became very depressed
because I'm a people
person and
eventually well eventually I followed
the second half of our state motto and
Live Free or Die there things worse than
death and that's what I decided and I
decided being so depressed was worse and
I did start seeing people
Outdoors um without my mask private
private Le so you know so I could go
places that people weren't enforcing
that I had a mask on and understood that
I really couldn't wear a mask but people
that's that's the individual as opposed
collectivist I do believe that in the ex
emergency orders that the governor did
Issue there was an exemption um for
people with medically related things and
I think that's important to note that we
as a state did Implement that go ahead
represent
bill that is indeed uh it's an important
distinction especially the from the
legal front but as as we've heard um
there was such
a a environment or atmosphere of of fear
and not just fear because we can't stop
there there was an attitude of
hatred that came along with all of these
things that happened that I know some
people even if it was not what they
wanted to do were wearing masks even
with health conditions because they did
not want to be accosted at the grocery
store by people who would be offended
that they weren't taking their
collectivist responsibilties
seriously represent
leus well that was something that I did
learn was that people don't actually
read governor 's uh
orders I obviously had read them I mean
as a rep we had to know what was going
on right and I knew that I didn't have
to wear the
mask
but most people didn't and you try to go
into a business you try to go into just
about any place that wasn't somebody's
home even somebody's home um and be told
that's the law and you'd have to explain
no it's actually not the law
but people didn't know and even when you
explained that they didn't necessarily
believe you and so there were a lot of
places instituting what they thought was
the law which was not and I
was I would not just about Mass but
about a number of things we'd G you know
the whole tracking and go to a
restaurant and leaving your phone number
and all of that kind of
stuff there were so many things that if
you read the governor's
orders it's they said one thing and if
you went into any kind of business or
whatever they said completely something
completely different because they
thought they were following the
law
well it's kind of like a catch
22 yes we had the emergency orders and
they were open but they were also
considered a private business so they
can enact their own protocols
just to be clear represent black I got
that I got that and and certainly if a
private business said to me this is our
policy that's fine but a lot of them
were doing it because they thought they
were following the law and that was the
thing that I really noticed
representative beler thank you madam
chair and to follow with that it's it's
a matter of which law or which guidance
was being followed because
let me tell you when when we were at the
height of the pandemic and I I would go
into businesses or doctor's offices or
wherever I don't recall once seeing the
governor's emergency order posted on the
front door but what I did see was
guidance from the CDC or the who or
other organizations that in many cases
was substantially different than what
was actually the law or or the executive
orders here in New Hampshire so I think
there there was probably a lot of uh
confusion and a lot of people unsure of
where to look where I think there was a
lot of people unsure of what the actual
Authority was of the various entities
putting these things in place whether
Governor's executive orders trumped the
CDC or the who or whether the hospitals
guidelines trumped what or I think I
think there was a lot of confusion
involved and people kind of defaulted to
the strictest set of
guidelines uh represent Bel I I do agree
with you we heard here from commissioner
edbl um Commissioner of
Education that they sent down some
guidelines but School boards chose the
CDC or the who guidelines uh so instead
of following New Hampshire guidelines
they went to the federal
guidelines and I think
you
know I don't know how we do this in the
future but I think it needs to be
extremely clear that you know New
Hampshire has its guidelines it needs to
be spelled out it needs to be saying
that we are actually looking out for Ev
every individual in our state we are
concerned about you and these are the
guidelines that we're instituting
because we feel that it is the most
appropriate for the individuals and the
citizens in our state um yes you'll be
hearing other other
guidelines but those are
generalized um you know we see this all
the time right represent
beler thank you madam chair and again we
can we can tie in whether we ever decide
to put this in any report but I would
make the argument
that um Powers such as were exercised
during a
pandemic such as quarantine for instance
are inherently police
Powers police powers are inherently a
power of the
state I am not personally aware of
anywhere where police Powers have
generally been delegated by the state to
the federal government and certainly not
to any
supernational uh organization or
governance um so it it would be
my um view that this is one of those
matters under the 10th Amendment where
the state the state Authority ought
reign
supreme I do believe though that if you
clicked on protocols on certain websites
at the state level they would bring you
to the CDC
guidelines so if we have under emergency
orders one set of
guidelines but then an agency's website
is
issuing the federal
guidelines or the Department of
Education says one thing but we're still
issuing under like you know like I said
in another department the federal
guidelines there is some confusing data
out there for the public um
we find this all the time um especially
in agriculture uh
confusion so I think trying to
streamline and make sure that all the
everybody's on the same page and maybe
that's something that should go in the
report that the guidelines should be the
guidelines for the
state um and it should be uniform across
all
agencies
[Music]
um so I don't know how that would happen
I don't know
um you know what the protocol of that
would be but I think it's it's because
when people start getting conflicting
information and it happens a lot uh in a
lot of different areas um it's tough um
you know especially when you're dealing
with the whole emotional thing of Co and
you know how many people were leaving
their groceries outside and then washing
them down before they brought them in
their
house um or people were afraid to come
outside even I mean even though we know
fresh air is healthy but just the fear
instilled but if you have conflicting
how how do people know what's true and
what's not representative P up then
representative
Bel and um following up on idea that
approach that was implemented was SSS
cheese approach when everything possible
was used uh in reality I think uh it was
not everything and uh we saw some
mandates when some measures were hardly
pushed or even mandated but at the same
time um at some time period so for the
whole period we saw some measures
were prohibited uh in some or other way
and like we know that in this state
there was a lot of discussion if people
should be uh uh it should be easier for
people to use tin uh for treatment and
the was push against this so it was not
like Swiss CH in this regard like we're
saying oh this approach is now good even
for masking like I probably
overreacted and played on safe side so I
was one of the maybe first people who
wore a 95 mask among public when uh like
dmos hitch HW Hospital nobody
from their staff was wearing any mask
and part of it was probably trying to
save PP uh saving equipment for part of
it maybe trying to not instill Panic so
at some point they were like okay not
wear a mask don't ins still panic and
then they're like not wear mask not
panic panic um so so uh some measures uh
I probably can come up with other
examples uh with antibodies like for a
while monoclonal antibodies were not
recommended uh so it's kind of the
removed from Swiss cheese approach and
then they were kind of they were
nationalized so they they started to be
recommended but you couldn't do it like
privately or on state level you had to
like wait for federal government to
distribute your fair share of monoclonal
antibodies for covid treatment so it's
again it was like kind of very limited
so so represent P what you're saying is
that although the Swiss cheese approach
was
applied
prevention there was that was opposite
of what was applied for treatment is
that
correct more like it's was more
nuanced situation than just Swiss ch's
approach so yeah I tried to use many
measures both for prevention and for
treatment but then quite a few measures
that should have been used were not used
so it's it I I see it as more complex
than just uh applying every possible
measure that is
reasonable thank you represent Belair
thank you madam chair just to return to
the idea of the the powers and the
different guidance coming from different
entities what I might
recommend is that if police powers are
rightly the power of the state and these
fall under the category of police Powers
then all guidance that has the effect or
force of law
ought to be coming from the state and
only the state now that's not to say
that people out there can't can't follow
CDC or who or whatever guidance they
want to because they're free people but
if it's going to carry the effect of law
it should only be coming from the state
and that also doesn't mean that the
state can't do what the CDC is doing for
instance it just has to adopt it as the
state's guidance not CDC guidance to say
this is our guidance which means they
they have not only the authority to to
do it but they also carry the liability
of doing it because one of the biggest
problems I see with this whole
situation is that it seems like the
entire thing has from the federal level
to the who to the state level to the
executive to everywhere it seems like
it's formed a web of bureaucracy that
has managed to spread responsibility and
liability so thin that nobody can be
held to account for anything and and the
buck doesn't stop anywhere for anything
that happen happened so it seems like
for my two cents state only should be
issuing guidance that carries the effect
of Law and it also shouldn't be able to
take any um any federal dollars that
come with requirements to issue things
that have the effective law because that
violates the 10th Amendment and the
separation of authority and powers
between the state and federal
government could you expound on that a
little bit when you talk about um that
we shouldn't be taking Federal money uh
thank you thank you in this particular
case what I what I mean is that if there
are if there is federal money that comes
with any mandates that we going to
affect on the people that would
represent police Powers because
everything we do from requiring masks to
quarantine those are all police Powers
so the federal government isn't really
supposed to have police Powers so if
they're trying to get around that by
saying well we're going to going to give
you money but only if you enact these
police Powers that's actually a
violation of the separation of authority
between the state and federal government
and that should be in my eyes that
unconstitutional so maybe when we have
um director buckton and we will be able
to uh find out if there were any
mandates I mean any um
representative
leus something that was touched on that
I think we really need to focus on was
the um treatments and the
limitations of the
treatments there were was seemed to be
an awful lot of
doctors and hospitals who were part of
organizations who could not give
treatments that private doctors were
giving very
successfully
and I would like to know more about how
that all came to be what the who was
making those decisions and why were many
of the pharmacies even if a h even if a
doctor
prescribed one of those medications like
ior mecanism just a for
example um why then were they
unavailable why were pharmacies refusing
to fill
them when that was a medicine that is
supply so represent let let me see if I
understand what you're
saying you're saying that private
doctors
were issuing different
medications than say and I I'm I'm
confused about private versus others
okay if you could expound on that a
little bit and the other question is are
you saying that pharmacists in New
Hampshire were refusing to refill uh
fill a prescription from New Hampshire
doctors so um the private versus
organization
the doctors who were part of
organizations were being told from
higher up in their organization you
can't do this or you'll be
fired so when you say an organization so
um well I I'll just use uh so like you
have conquered hospital and a lot you
have a lot of doctors under the umbrella
of conquered hospital is that what
you're considering an organization yes
versus like a concierge doctor or
someone in private practice like
somebody who's part of say Dartmouth
Hitchcock for instance Dartmouth
Hitchcock doctors all had to follow Dr
Dartmouth Hitchcock procedure you know
all across the state if they were
Affiliated they had to follow those
whatever those guidelines were those
with Southern New Hampshire which I
forget what
their current name
is but those had to follow those rules
and um
if you were a private doctor who was not
affiliated with anybody else you could
then because it wasn't federally illegal
you could do things that you could not
do under the guidance of whoever oversaw
or without threat of being fired okay so
you just said something and I just want
to see you said federally
illegal um you said that they you
know so I'm I'm trying to really grasp
dive into what you're saying there so if
you
so partly it's what you prescribe and it
might be FDA approved but you can't
prescribe it because you've been told
not to but another part of that that we
came across was um um getting
medical exceptions for taking
um where did that where did that
guidance come from because there were
doctors there was one that I know of who
really wanted to give a medical
exemption for one of his
patients it was a nurse um so that she
didn't have to get vaccinated in order
to keep working and was
basically said I can't give this to you
or I will lose my job that's coming from
above but I I she had he had already
told her I don't think you should ever
take another vaccine from the reaction
you had with the last one you may have a
complete allergic reaction which she did
and apparently with within like seven
seconds of having died from the amount
of time she wasn't breathing before they
were able to start her breathing again
after she got the vaccine where did that
come from who made those
decisions okay so I'm just going to
rephrase this just so for for
understanding purposes and I think it
ties
into what the mom that we heard
that the daughter had some issues and
but the
medical doctor said no no you should
this person here um the doctor knew that
this person should not receive the
vaccine
however he couldn't give her the
exemption because the organization or
somebody says you cannot give any
medical
exemptions um
so the nurse it's my understanding based
on what you just said did receive the
vaccine and she had a terrible
breathing
so the question comes is when the
medical industry says they will do no
harm
even though they're told that they know
something is going to be harmful to
someone but they're
taking their Li but then they have to
weigh in their livelihood over something
that's
harmful
um what does that do to that particular
doctor especially knowing that this
person just in order to keep her
job did exactly was trying to avoid
exactly what he told that doctor told
her not to do he couldn't follow his own
guidance and knew it was medically right
person
so there seems to be a moral conflict
somewhere in
here
and I think that's something that's
important to note and you're not the
first person that has told me of a story
similar to this
um so this
isn't it's more prevalent than what we
we we we would think
and it should be caused for concern for
everybody because if they're telling you
over something that they know is going
to harm you because of a your condition
or something
how many other times are they doing that
in other
instances not related to
covid representative Belcher thank you
madam chair and on a on a very similar
topic I I would love to get somebody
who's capable of
testifying um particularly to the uh the
expert analysis of scientific study
because one of the things things I've
heard more and more recently um
particularly regarding some of the
Pharmaceuticals that we've we've been uh
sort of alluding to here is that there's
this concept
within um within statistics and Analysis
called a funnel
plot a funnel
plot and the idea is that within sort of
MAA analysis of studies meaning you're
looking at a bunch of different studies
on the same topic
that you can apply this concept called
The Funnel
plot and it will give you an idea as to
whether there has been bias in the
published
research and what I've heard is
that an awful lot of uh pharmaceutical
research that comes out these days
actually fails the funnel plot which
suggests that there's selective
publication of certain um themes either
for or against certain
Pharmaceuticals um as if there's a bias
involved so I would love to hear more
about uh about that from uh experts in
the field to learn if there is indeed um
bias on the part of the major journals
who are publishing these sorts of
research um why that might be are there
incent incentives in place that would uh
cause that to come about um is there
ideological reasons are there financial
reasons um and what ultimately
recommendations we might be able to make
to
um correct any any uh any problems that
might
exist and could you uh tell me where
fall sure because we we there obviously
within the state level there were
recommendations and or mandates for
various pharmaceutical products um both
in terms of preventatives and treatments
that would speak to whether or not the
expert evaluation of these
Pharmaceuticals um were subjected to a
bias-free
evaluation um or whether there was a
incentive structure or narrative or
ideology or anything else in place that
might have tilted the balance away from
Pure science and towards something
else so what you're saying is not only
the mandates for preventative basically
the Swiss cheese approach but there are
also mandates uh for when you received
when you had covid and there were
mandates by the
state sure uh mandates Andor
recommendations um but in either case
mandates or recommendations would have
certainly been based on what would be
called consensus or expert opinion
expert opinion would have of course
taken into account the Publications in
major research journals everything from
you know science to Nature um so if
there's a problem at the heart of that
right down to the bias possibility of
bias being introduced at the level of
publishing in major research journals
that would trickle down all the way to
the guy ID and and uh mandates being
recommended by state Personnel regarding
uh both treatments and preventatives for
covid um and if there's a problem there
I mean if if there's a problem at that
deepest level that would taint
everything all the way down the line so
I'd like to know more about
that uh and I'm just going to be a
little adversarial here I
mean there's bias in
everything um so I guess the question is
is um I'm a numbers person it's kind of
black and white they either say this or
they say that you really can't
manipulate them too much um so what
you're saying
is is the data being purely uh presented
as the data or is it being manipulated
in
some yes and I would like to do that I
would like to hear that's that's why I
want to hear from an expert in
scientific and statistical analysis who
can come in here and explain to us what
is a funnel plot is it true that within
pharmaceutical research it often fails a
funnel plot such that it highly suggests
bias in
publication um and why that might be uh
because again we're science-based and I
want to do this in science by the
numbers and statistics is I think one of
the better ways to go about looking at
that so if if it if it fails a funnel
plot if there's evidence of
packing um which is a way to manipulate
statistical results um I think we should
know if that's happening um or
not represent
POA thank you Madame chair I want to
follow up on
representative leus um testimonia and uh
uh in my view it's uh important for us
to trying to understand um where it came
from uh when people were denied uh
proper exemptions from vaccination and
we know it's not limited just for
hospitals we heard many stories about um
military personnel uh were
widely um denied any exemptions I
personally know um New England policeman
uh who was uh
fired uh because he was in the process
of um getting exemption and it was
impossible it was made impossible he was
not the only one and it took him I don't
know how many like uh two years how many
finally uh a number of them won in the
court and uh uh
reinstated but uh the damage was already
done uh to the public and uh people by
it's I want to know why why doctors were
pushed and who pushed them to deny
exemptions represent vure thank you
madam chair and thank you for that uh
representative bazov because that is
actually an avenue I would like to
explore a little bit as well because it
does seem to me and I'd like to explore
a little bit of the case law history and
what not behind this because it seems to
me
that historically when people were to
seek conscientious or religious
exemptions they would simply do so and
say I have a I have a conscientious or
religious ex exemption or or qualm with
what is being proposed and at that point
the burden of proof would shift to the
person administering the exemption to
require a hefty burden of proof to
disprove that claim before they could
deny it but what I saw under Co and I
experienced this with close friends of
mine as well was in some cases it was
flipped seemingly so that the burden of
proof
was placed on the person requesting the
exemption to such an extent that they
would require letters written from their
pastors requiring specific scriptural
references to why this is not in line
with your beliefs your sincerely held
beliefs as well as requests for your own
medical history and if you had ever for
instance had a flu vaccine before you're
going to need to explain why this is now
different than that and the it's a
really really extremely high burden of
proof was placed on some of the people
seeking exemptions rather than the other
way around which seems like the more
thing if anybody knows anybody um that
uh has that background that could come
to the committee uh just please contact
us and let us know and we'd be more than
willing um uh to hear from them um
so yeah there this is there's a lot um
to go through here
um and
uh you know as we put think about what
we're doing who we're going to be
hearing from and of course we'd always
love to hear from the public um we're
also have to be thinking about how our
report's going to look and how we're
going to put together
that um so just want to throw
that representative Bel if I may if this
is an appropriate time I'd like to offer
some some thoughts as to how I sort of
envisioned the uh the most sort of
possible ideal looking report um might
be might look um so I was thinking I
think the best way to start at this you
know the 30,000 foot view is to start by
breaking it down topically I think to do
it chronologically would be too
difficult to cause people to jump around
and try to find instances of their of
whatever they're looking for in 10
different places rather than just one um
and then and then within the broader
topical breakdown I in order to maintain
a uniformity between each section I
think we should have uh the same sort of
um chapters or whatever you might want
to call them within each topic and I
think those should include uh testimony
received which will not be comprehensive
but it will pull out selected testimony
that is impactful and and pertinent to
what we're doing and say this is what
we've received this is what we've been
told by members of the public and
experts um a section in under each topic
for um any persons who have made
allegations or grievances for us to
examine um incentive mechanisms that may
have been established by any uh by
anyone
um impacts on constitutional rights uh
our role
in sure uh incentive
mechanisms impacts on constitutional
rights uh our role regarding judicial
and executive
oversight um federalist or federalism
implications state federal
relations um a section on demonstrable
facts which will probably be one of the
shorter ones because it's actually going
to be hard to fully establish um what is
uncontroverted fact versus mere um
probab probabilities
um a section on areas of variable
certainty or uncertainty um I kind of
Envision that more like a a an
intelligence type breakdown where we can
attribute a medium low or high degree of
confidence in in various items that
we're looking at um
areas for further
investigation and by whom should that be
conducted um recommendations and avenues
for redress of
grievance uh recommendations for
legislative
action and recommendations for future
emergent events such as other pandemics
and of course I think all of this should
include um positive Lessons Learned as
well things that we might have done well
compared to to other states other
nations um as well as the uh of course
received I thank you for uh putting uh
that together and being very thoughtful
on that I think it's important that we
highlight the positives um but I also
think it's important uh that as we look
to the Future and just in hearing from
Dr pull off with the Infectious Disease
doctor that when we look at an another
pandemic or something coming down the
pike that we really need to look at you
know Break It Out by uh demographics or
age groups or who's the most affected
and relo protocols accordingly um as we
learned um because I really truly
believe that the mental health of the
public should should be at the
Forefront uh of the mental health of the
individual I should say should be at the
Forefront of everything that we do
um
because I have a saying that attitude is
basically most of everything um and
keeping positive and knowing that we're
going to get through things
[Music]
um really has a lot to do with
health and
um I think we need to make sure that uh
when we roll something out or do
something in the
future we
also it shouldn't be all doom and gloom
we we really need to put in our that
there's there is a solution that there
is an answer that there is positivity
and I think positivity is something that
we really really need to
stress um because I don't think that was
done during the pandemic represent
leus there's a book that I read that
looks at survivors and they looked at a
plane crash in particular and those who
survived and those who did not even
though they might be sitting right next
to each other in the seats and they
looked at the differences and they
looked at then other instances and they
came up with a number of criteria
that helps with survival and perhaps
that's something we should look at and
think about for the future it's like how
did we or did we not do those things
because part of that is the attitude
there are a number of things like that
and for instance the whole
fear-mongering works to the opposite of
survival and so perhaps that is
we um push or promote the things that
work towards
survival and how much did we push or
promote the things that work against it
and what can we do in the future to work
towards
survival representative Belcher thank
you madam chair and and and to go into
that same the same topic and mental
health obviously being a very important
topic um I know myself and perhaps
mothers here have just recently finished
a book by Abigail shrier called bad
therapy going over some of the really
detailed
analysis and uh speaking with experts
and interviews as
to sort of the nature of our therapeutic
environment that we find ourselves in
and um one of the things that really
stood out to me in that book was that
resilience is the default human
position um absent any other you know
intervening things people tend to be
resilient and that can be demonstrated
based on look looking at things such as
the variable PTSD rates um in different
populations populations that are um
relatively you know well
off yet steeped in uh a therapeutic
environment actually find that they have
very much higher PTSD rates than
populations that have very diff ult
lives um but are not steeped in the
therapeutic environment and how
that direction may have played into our
pandemic response in a detrimental and
paradoxical
way could you go into that just a little
bit further because if I heard you
correctly just want to make sure that
the people that had um more
difficulties and didn't have uh therapy
readily
available had less
PTSD than those that were more affluent
and had therapy readily available is
that correct kind of not not exactly but
kind of so it's not it's not exactly
therapy readily available it's more a
matter of being steeped in a therapeutic
environment and and so let me expound on
that the idea of rumination the idea of
sitting with yourself in your thoughts
and thinking about yourself
and it's been said by some particularly
famous therapist that there is little
difference between sitting around
thinking of yourself and being depressed
it is I almost the same
thing
so those steeped in a culture of
rumination and thinking about themselves
more tend to have worse mental health
outcomes and more
diagnoses than those in more difficult
circumstances who don't spend time
rumination ruminating uh another way to
look at it is your your mindset there's
two primarily different mindsets you can
take toward the world one is a mindset
of self and one is a mindset of task the
first mindset being you're you're
spending your time you're looking at
everything through a lens of how is this
affecting my mental health how am I
feeling about this the other mindset is
how do I get this task done and what you
find is that the more time you spend in
mindset a thinking about
self the worse mental health outcomes
you are and the less you were capable of
getting done in life which also affects
your mental health than somebody who is
Task oriented so it might be worth
exploring how we responded in terms of
mental health to this pandemic in terms
of did we promote rumination did we
promote this theraputic mindset of
sitting with yourself and thinking about
yourself which is functionally no
different than being depressed and how
did that impact US versus could we have
directed people in a task oriented way
with goals where they might have
actually felt good about themselves and
brought people together instead of the
alternative representative leus just
following on with that how much did the
lockdowns contribute to just sitting
around looking at
yourself as opposed to being able to do
things
off yeah to follow up on last two um for
me the focus is more like
uh like people need to information to
act upon like there was some active uh
measures like people were thinking how
to uh
create more masks or like how to brw
their own uh hand sanitizer but for me
focus is more like instead of informing
people it was more like instilling fa
with
constant daily daily press briefings but
also like focusing on number of people
who died and all the negatives that come
Vis it and it was always uh
some running line in the news uh and uh
more on federal level but on state level
it was similar so for
was of course there was place for ration
but there was a lot of fair fair
even even without termination
scared if anybody has anything else they
would like to say or discuss um I did
have this continued for 1:00 I don't
know if we need
to uh do that
or um and I'm not sure what the protocol
is um where the meeting is
listed um represent
lus well when I talked earlier about
treatment protocols we then got off into
medical exemptions Etc but I still would
like to to
pursue medical protocols and the fact
that there were out there and
published um Medical protocols that were
being um
successful and then the inability to
follow those
protocols
and just basically where did that come
from how to that H Etc is that something
you'd like to discuss this afternoon go
into depth more or no I would like to
have speaking of somebody to come in and
talk to us you know we read all those
things things of course they kept being
um
say so so it would be nice if we could
get someone uh from the hospital
Association in here and I will see what
I can do but if anybody else knows
represent
beler thank you I I think we've covered
just about everything that I wanted to
get into here today there's one final
thing I'd like to do with permission to
make an appeal to the public um
regarding our uh regarding
advertisements now we we seek to get to
the B botom of issues regarding what
guidance was issued as well as different
funding and What mechanisms may come
along with that in order to do that most
effectively I believe we would like to
have in hand any advertisements that
were made for any uh treatment or
guidance or protocols or anything of
that nature Made by the state of New
Hampshire or Affiliated persons um
whether that's you know a a picture that
was taken of a billboard or something
from a magazine or any of the above
because if we have those in hand we can
ask specifically to this advertisement
was this bought with State funds with
federal funds what strings were attached
to it and I I'd like to have all of that
as part of our record so if any of the
MERS of the public watching um have any
of that uh please find it give it to us
uh email it to us bring it into US
however you'd like to we would like to
hand thank you for that uh anybody
else
okay well then I will adjourn the
meeting and thank you all for attending
and thank you all
[Music]
um for everything everyone have a
wonderful weekend it's going to be